es posible que a usted oa un ser querido
le hayan diagnosticado linfoma este
vídeo le ayudará a entender más sobre
este tipo de cáncer y cómo afecta a su
cuerpo
el sistema linfático formó parte del
sistema inmunológico el cual protege al
cuerpo de las infecciones y enfermedades
es una red de órganos y vasos que
filtran la linfa para eliminar
microorganismos y partículas extrañas
el líquido filtrado regresa a la sangre
y los órganos linfáticos como los
ganglios linfáticos tienen un tipo de
glóbulo blanco denominado linfocito los
dos tipos principales de linfocitos son
los linfocitos b y los linfocitos t el
linfoma es un cáncer que se origina en
los linfocitos los linfomas de
linfocitos b son los más comunes los
linfocitos crecen y se multiplican en el
tejido linfático lo cual da lugar a más
células anormales que no funcionan como
es debido los dos tipos principales de
linfoma son el linfoma de hodgkin y el
linfoma no-hodgkin
el tipo más común de linfoma de hodgkin
es el linfoma de hodgkin clásico las
células cancerosas en el linfoma de
hodgkin clásico se conocen como células
de reed sternberg y generalmente son un
tipo anormal de linfocitos b dichas
células anormales tienden a propagarse
de manera ordenada de un grupo de
ganglios linfáticos a otro
a menudo el linfoma no-hodgkin se
origina en los linfocitos b pero también
puede originarse en los linfocitos t el
linfoma no-hodgkin tiende a propagarse
de manera menos ordenada a través del
sistema linfático
los síntomas del linfoma varían de
acuerdo con el tipo de linfoma y de su
ubicación en el cuerpo en ocasiones el
linfoma no presenta síntomas sin embargo
los síntomas de ambos tipos de linfoma
suelen incluir ganglios linfáticos
inflamados en el cuello las axilas o la
ingle fiebre sudores nocturnos pérdida
de peso sensación de mucho cansancio y
picazón de la piel o erupción cutánea
como parte del diagnóstico su médico
intentará averiguar la magnitud de la
enfermedad y si se ha propagado esto se
denomina esta edificación
los estadios del linfoma varían de 1 a 4
y pueden variar según el tipo de linfoma
en general cuanto más bajo sea el
estadio menor será el desarrollo del
cáncer los estadios más altos indican un
mayor desarrollo del cáncer se desconoce
la causa del linfoma sin embargo hay
factores que aumentan el riesgo
ser de edad avanzada pero ser joven
también son factores de riesgo en el
caso de algunos tipos de linfoma la
infección con ciertos virus tales como
el virus de inmunodeficiencia humana vih
o el virus de epstein-barr
y tener un sistema inmunológico
debilitado y antecedentes familiares de
linfoma
al enfrentarse a un diagnóstico de
linfoma continúe hablando con su médico
y con su equipo de atención médica del
cáncer